mélenchon qui chouine toute la journée
devant la caméra j'ai une perquisition
et ya trop de pathos de l'autre côté
mais la france insoumise vous êtes un
pays a vraiment réception va passer
c'est arrivé la veille ces combattants
avaient dû patienter un peu avec mon
truc que je suis porte parole de la
france en tweed je ne le suis pas allé
porte parole de cyril hanouna maintenant
c'est ici tu penses sérieusement comment
montrer mes idées on me dise qualifiant
par rapport à mon parcours personnel de
femme engagée que je n'ai pas besoin de
les contrôler elle même toi tu es un
maquereau nist ah ben voilà tu adores
les prévoit comme tu dis c'est pas comme
ça on va là puisque tu viendras en
valeur - t'as quoi comme preuve à
l'appui ce que tu veux maintenant moi je
suis ma croisade
c'est ce que soit respectée avec les
insoumis j'ai quelques preuves en effet
et c'est assez bien dans des rapports
comment ça s'est assez bien documenté te
fais pas de l'aimer rapports actuels à 4
ans insoumise ils sont comment tu as
gardé le logiciel de la pandémie accroc
et la misogynie
tu vois tu es en train de faire
exactement la même chose avant parce que
me faire passer moi pour juste les
pouces 2 c'est la base
s'il vous plaît si on fait appel
attendez voir ces jeunes suivent ils
viennent aux qu'il aimera qu'elle
craquait et éric bacqua qu'elle pense
que vous avez voulu dire comme celle
épouse d'alexis corbeyran voilà alors
les rachats se blesser lors c'est le
bras les rapports politiques à la france
je dis simplement que ce que tu viens de
développer sur la monarchie
présidentielle c'est un des dadas de la
france a soumis ses écrits dessus 6e
rétabli la france est soumise avec nos
lendemains qui firent livre qui se
targue d'être un grand lecteur physique
nous faisons lui s'appelle guy ses
écrits sont des photos d'un film de
peter lecteurs
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît ma vie est ce que j'ai
dit où les colis non higgins la 6ème
république
raquel garrido c'est paru chez fayard en
démon charge les morts je le note je
vais le lion c'est quoi l'histoire un
niveau moyen des mers y en a pour tous
deux secondes quoi et comment finir avec
la monarchie par des vaisseaux fini à
l'honneur sur cinq secondes je connais
la monarchie présidentielle c'est un des
vieux dada de la france insoumise et tu
enfourche son dada c'est haddad assure
non bis pelloquet score
[Applaudissements]
je suis jamais arrivé
ensuite nous racontent n'importe quoi
j'ai me handfield lecteurs j'ai pas
migros la monarchie présidentielle là où
elle est le mieux petits lecteurs
là où est le mieux illustré c'est quand
même à la france insoumise où il ya jean
luc mélenchon et sa cour qui s'aplatit
ce moment l'une celle à ces débats toute
la france a soumises
maintenant on est chez l'animateur a
soumis d'accord